we have a voicemail number that number
is 219 to David P a very good question
about monkeypox you know a lot of right
Wingers including Marjorie Taylor green
who we spoke about yesterday are framing
monkey pox as a gay disease they're sort
of talking about it like it's the new
AIDS or whatever and of course it's
merely coincidental that this initial
contagion group happened to be among gay
or bisexual men but it is already
spreading beyond that and this caller
asks a very good question
hey David Jeremy in Oregon here uh just
wanted to comment on this monkey pox
being a uh a homosexual disease what are
these conservatives that are saying this
gonna say when they come down with it
are they gay probably not and it'll be
dismissed and twisted into something
else yeah conspiracy we were infected by
George Soros or something no so here's
the deal
um at this point it seems like the
monkey pox cat is out of the proverbial
bag and we're already seeing people
other than gay men get it we're you know
gay men also have children and sometimes
they pick up their kids and so it's
obviously going to go bigger and
um the most like there's a couple
possibilities for how the right will
handle that one will be they'll say
okay like first it was from the covet
virus was from China but then thanks to
China it spread everywhere they'll go
with something similar they'll say gay
men seeded monkey pox in our communities
and now it's everywhere and it never
should have happened that's sort of one
possibility the other possibility is
yeah they'll just pretend they never
said the thing about it's a gay disease
they'll you know they're very
comfortable rewriting history
revisionist history that's a possibility
and the third one is yeah some other
conspiracy theory so they'll move on to
saying monkey pox is being shot with
some kind of Jewish gun by George Soros
or something like that
um something along those lines but
they'll come up with something else
whenever you think they won't be able to
talk their way out of this one because
the only explanation they could come up
with nobody would believe they come up
with an incredible explanation and their
followers believe it and they repeat it
so there's we've net we still have not
hit rock bottom that I can assure you we
have a tremendous bonus show for you
today
top Democrats I'm sorry top economists
agree
the health care and climate package that
Democrats want to pass
will put downward pressure on inflation
Republicans should want it right right
and Idaho abortion law has now drawn a
Justice Department lawsuit we will
discuss why
and thirdly Joe Biden's task force has
indeed now reunited 400 migrant children
separated from their families under
Trump it's been done quietly it's been
done relatively efficiently although it
does take some time to do it and we will
talk about the implications and the next
steps on that on today's bonus show
don't miss the bonus show you can sign
up at joinpakman.com it's one of many
great membership benefits it now comes
with an upgraded experience thanks to
some new elements of technology that
we've implemented on the member podcast
sign up today use the coupon code big
voting22 to get a discount and I will
see you then